what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the worst is if you're jerking off with
a hat on bro you're going to hell
that's the most french thing you can do
jacking off with them straw kentucky
derby has
yeah what's the worst hat to jack off
the worst hat to just probably a top hat
cause you have to balance yourself while
you're jerking off
one of them [ __ ] chimney sweep hats
the best will be one of those chinese
hats bro because if you squat down low
enough to the ground you can almost hide
under it and jerk off
those things would be dope bruh the most
confusing would be like one of them
daniel boone raccoon yeah but you got
that tail in your eye
you pushed it you're blowing the tails
in the way
the [ __ ] out of my way with this tape
the dutch are so aerodynamic
they move good now you ever seen a dutch
they're really aerodynamic they're
they're what what are you doing with
your hands lean face lean headed
no they're not four inches cheek to
cheek they're big people man dude
know how big they are the dutch oh
they're very tall but they're
very aerodynamic very aerodynamic the
downhill people they call them dude
going into the matrix theo
we're going into the matrix i'm gonna
get my stuff first
what would you bring if i said hey dude
you can go in the matrix but uh you can
bring three things
i'd have to bring a picture of my family
and then i'd have to bring probably
i'd bring probably some water
i would think you need water in the
matrix i'm not going to be the guy
without it in there
or maybe a toothbrush
dude you're the only person with a
freaking nice grill in the matrix you're
getting some puss bro
dude and cocaine oh go back to that vest
story man so here's what happened
so i you know i would get i would do
some cocaine a thousand put on these
different vests
how many did you buy again i don't know
i spent too much on them but
i would probably say the priciest one i
had was probably about 210.
nice damn yeah and so i would get [ __ ]
up and put these vests on and put on
sunglasses and not
no like buffalo bills [ __ ] but at least
partying by myself you know
and one time i was making a smoothie you
know because i you know i have
i got like a new i don't know what kind
of blender it is but it's pretty nice
and i was making like a nice smoothie
and i'm [ __ ] coked up i'm partying
you know i'm living high on the hog
two vests on maybe right and i thought i
thought i
heard something outside right which is
kind of weird to even think of
when you have a blender going right so i
leave out of my apartment to go in the
hallway
lock myself out with the blender going
2 30 in the morning coked up out of my
brain right now i have to go to my
landlord dude
who lives right down the hall oh no
activities you think you do where you
come a lot like the kind of people that
like
power lifters probably shoot giant loads
right dude this [ __ ] is getting
gay bro today sorry i gotta fight
it's just very dick oriented today i
wouldn't say it's gay well it's that
time of year it's spring
people are refreshed it's spring it's
the middle of the winter yeah it's
freezing cold out it's just
january whatever you guys don't know you
guys aren't open-minded
that's what i think it doesn't get more
winter than january
not even a groundhog's day yet why don't
i just say it's august
scooping up [ __ ] imagine if your grandma
just [ __ ] all over your yarn
just go out go on the lawn and just she
shits in the yard
shits on the lawn like grandma's out
there [ __ ] and i go clean up her [ __ ]
yeah i love her but god i hate cleaning
her [ __ ]
yeah i would hate cleaning up probably
human [ __ ] for some reason but i
remember than dog [ __ ]
well when i was a kid they had a boy in
our neighborhood named mario right
and he uh and he was dude he ended up
dying actually he did some pills and
drove into an embankment but he
when i was young he would [ __ ] in his
yard make me bury it
and that's how that's how i was allowed
to be friends with him
how did he make you bury it he just
asked me to do it and i was afraid not
to do it i think he said
yo dude you're not going to believe this
but i took a [ __ ] and um it's out of my
yard i can't even bury it because i'll
throw up
you do me a favor go bury it yeah he was
he dude he was dark man he had a he had
a real dark vision
and he would uh he would i mean he
probably honestly dude
he probably [ __ ] 200 300 times and i
buried it
i swear to god come on i swear to god
i swear to god dude and he um how'd you
not run out of places to make new holes
do you think you ever dug up old [ __ ] to
put in new [ __ ]
oh yeah i wouldn't be surprised man we
basically had like the only setup i had
not even have a strong system the only
setup i had was like a
one of those plastic uh you know beach
oh
like a beach set up dude i'm talking i
was seven so wait a minute this
seven-year-old was doing this how old
was he he was eight or nine oh he's
tricking you but yeah and older
he was older and two years when you're
seven is a long stretch
you know when you're 32 yeah 32-34 that
doesn't mean [ __ ] whatever dude
seven and nine that's a big stretch yeah
you go [ __ ] at your house buddy that's
what i tell people now
so for two what he would what was the do
you remember the first
there's no way you really remember i
remember what he said
i remember what he said but i remember
how did it happen how did it happen when
you find
yourself with a plastic shovel and
another person's [ __ ] going damn
how did it come to this well it came to
it
because he i know my brother probably
wasn't around and i wanted somebody to
play with and he was older so i was
hanging out
and he was deviant man how so he just
had a little bit of like
um like he was kind of slithering you
know what i'm talking about
he knew how to manipulate you yeah he
was obviously you buried his [ __ ] 200
plus times
like there wasn't he had the same color
in the outside of his eye on the inside
of his eye you know what i'm talking
about
demon yeah like a light d diablo yeah
like a el diablo but also who was in
elementary school
oh interesting um but he uh so when you
first found yourself
do you remember the the feeling that you
first found when you were
digging a hole for a dude [ __ ] like just
thinking what am i how long can i do
this what if he keeps asking
how do i stop this how did you wind up
stopping that's maybe a better question
you know what i don't remember how it
kind of you know pant you know how it
turned off yeah petered off
i don't remember how it kind of tapered
off his parents ever like hey do you
ever [ __ ] in the house
how come we don't have any missing
toilet paper well dude you know that's
what i think it was i think he was lazy
where you know he was
i'm serious and he sat outside behind
his slide they had a slide in his yard
because he had you know a little bit of
money
and he shot outside behind the slide
this is a great word too by the way and
it was silty kind of
soil and sand and i remember going over
there i still remember
doing yeah i'm telling jokes jesus
christ
yeah and then telling people when you go
back home and they've never seen you
they've never heard of you
they think you're gay they're just like
you won't like they're like you keep
flying home you don't have
any money and you're not bringing a girl
home you have these jokes
yeah you're hiding from something you
know just come out i remember my stepdad
is yelling at me in the yard one time
told you to come out
yeah i was like i'm not [ __ ] gay bro
i was like i'm just not flying some girl
home that i just met
you know just to prove to you i can't
catch you i thought you could catch it
alive
the worst has got to be if someone says
you're gay and you are but you don't
want to oh yeah that'd be sick
[ __ ] yeah you changed your clothes the
next day you come dressed like in a
mafia outfit or something like something
to totally
take them hot off the trail you know the
meat the uh
oh you ate them you're saying yeah but
the you guys ate owls
yeah i think that's legal you probably
shouldn't say that on the podcast
well i didn't have a lot
i'll tell you this if you want to feed a
family of four you can't
just have one owl i will say that though
well if you look at what it looks like
without the feathers it looks like
i'm saying [ __ ] demon yeah you know
it's a real baiting switch i feel like
it's one of god's hidden agendas well i
was talking to someone about peacocks
about this i started talking about it on
stage i don't know yeah that's a duck
bro
but it's it says peacock that is
something else that is
right though go back up to the peacock
picture they ever just dropped that
rabbit said [ __ ] it
and i stopped the car and to check it
out i was like whoa that's flirting
really it sounds like
flirting oh
yeah it's ready to [ __ ] probably yeah
like you didn't love the french i love
the canadians
french canadians yeah i'll take them you
love canadians
period i love canadians period but do
you love french canadians
yes because they are canadian but french
bro
not into french and nobody is they make
great wine
yeah that's not true people go to paris
every year yeah but they leave
it's not the kind of place people are
milling around man
like if a plane crashed i already know
i'm planning ahead dude i need a
vietnamese guy
why um because that's easy it's a
starter move if you attack somebody
bigger
if you eat somebody bigger in front of
other people it's going to alarm people
but you you got to eat a small person so
stature is important
i think if you gum down a viet people
aren't going to be that upset at you
vietnam means people are going to be
super upset what are you talking about
somebody's dad
yeah they're sacrificed they're more
understanding of things dude
is this a character you're playing no
but if you eat a black dude you eat a
black lady and her family's there
they're going to be pissed
so you think a vietnamese person will
let you slide i think that they'd be
much more forgiving over a couple of day
period
i think they're relatives you don't
think so honestly
one thing no i don't think so i
definitely think they'd be super pissed
at you
especially modernized ones but what is
interesting is like vietnam is one of
the few places where
um americans can go back to vietnam and
they don't seem to
hold any grudge at all exhibit a
[Laughter]
exhibit a man honestly well asian people
in general are just
much more forgiving and understanding it
seems like i feel like
i think i mean i don't have much i think
i think that's a giant generalization
it probably is you know i mean i did a
fast for like four days and then i was
at the best buy
and um and i remember this vietnamese
guy was trying to help me out and i
couldn't even hear him i was so hungry
and i couldn't you did a fast for four
days oh dude yeah
what are you trying to prove i don't
know man i was probably just dealing
with some stuff and i was just trying to
find a different way to handle it you
know
right um and then i remember this
vietnamese guy
and i remember thinking if everybody
turned the other way for a second i
could eat this young fella you know
ben his name was ben actually over there
in westwood
um but and i've never thought it's so
ridiculous
well i mean but here's the thing i'd
never thought that before so you only
thought you got to the verge of
cannibalism after just four days
yeah damn how much weight did you lose i
probably lost about
four pounds but pounds i needed too you
know but i got clear man i could
and i could hear i swear to god y'all
could hear somebody fold a piece of
bread from 80 feet away bro
i was so hungry dude i could hear a
[ __ ] skittle hit the cement
across the street i really i think you
would think they do but for their size
and stuff they're not doing that much
who do you think shoots the biggest
loads oh i think a guy that's in space
i think a guy that's on a cliff like a
cliff
climber yeah but is that the biggest
loads
i mean that guy's shooting some [ __ ]
just because he has the balls to climb
up like that he's busting some real
spackle maybe that's what it is like
he's got balls like those guys shoot
bigger loads yeah
like bmx jumpers they jump three times
in the end and land on the bike yeah
maybe they have the biggest loads um
also
guys who like fake put a sign on their
car when they don't pay a meter it's
like meters broken and they just put
that on their car if i can still park
there
those dudes bust some loads bro
i think there's other things too like
pickpockets oh people that wear
turtlenecks
do not come very much or far no what is
it about wanting to keep your neck warm
it's not very manly it's just a [ __ ]
move out
it's such some french thing too
and i don't care about the french humans
yeah just people that are just
smoking their own dicks out there who
have no real life like you know what i'm
saying like i've met some people who
yeah they're breathing but that's it
really yeah this idea that we're all
created equals
you've never met anybody that's a genius
if you say that i've met some people
that i'm like i talked to him i go oh
i'm like a monkey
yeah compared to you
[Laughter]
dude i talked to your buddy eddie bravo
and that guy is a real
he's out there he's like a jet he's like
a deaf like a deaf jack russell almost
you know a deaf
jack russell yeah because once he gets
going you can't oh jack russell terrier
yeah you ever been around one of those
dogs you opened the car and then the
next thing you know they're at the
yeah they're like sick yeah but how's he
deaf because you can't get him back
like once he goes you can't you know i
was saying you can't get him back in the
car
like you're sitting there honking the
horn you can't that guy's out there
you know my home you know what i'm
talking about i do know what he talked
about
but i've never heard anybody make a
description like that
jack russell terrier that is hilarious
he's extravagant dude
yeah do you think you see yourself ever
going to church again yeah i would think
so i think church
is kind of evolving over our time and
stuff like that and
um would you go to justin bieber's
preacher carl lentz
you know who he is yeah whoa he texted
me actually whoa
he's trying to groom you trying to pull
you in is he a dark art
how low do you wear your shorts huh oh i
saw you guys making fun of his roots
yeah that was a little wild huh so you
know him i've never met him
no you just text each other back and
forth yeah we communicate sometimes
yeah that's that root hashtag dickroot
handsome
but i've never met him but i would go to
each other
yeah just try to meet you and you're
like not tonight bro
you think he's homoerotic no oh no i
mean
that's a weird way of putting it i think
you're homoerotic what
bro you're way gayer than me bro you
always
every time i'm here you talk about
jerking off the magical hat we almost
wore
what about that problem it's like you
came in here with like gay expectations
no i got
nothing dude
you